all right this is absolutely bizarre
rudy guiliani or Giuliani Donald Trump's
personal attorney may be former I guess
we don't really know at this point
what's going on Rudy appeared on TV on
none other than Fox News he was
interviewed by Trump brown-noser Maria
Bartiromo
and those are there there are two
different things here that are bonkers
about this video first is what Rudy
Giuliani says because Rudy Giuliani now
is jumping on the train and he is going
on TV and pushing chloroquine as a
treatment for coronavirus Rudy is not a
doctor Trump is not a doctor actual
doctors are saying it's worth trying and
controlled trials along with dozens of
other things but the early results seem
very 50/50 about chloroquine of course
if Trump is saying it then everybody
around Trump is saying it so Rudy
Giuliani now recommending medications on
TV so we're gonna play that but the
other crazy thing about this video is
that Rudy Giuliani looks like he's had
half of a haircut in this video what I
mean is one side of Rudy Giuliani's head
looks like he has a short haircut like
he's almost shaved his head the other
side doesn't it's very odd so if you're
watching look at the left side of Rudy's
head meaning the right side of your
screen and you'll see a ton of hair
that's all puffed up and his hair on the
right side of his head you're left
looking at the screen is gone it's a
very weird thing and contributing to
Rudy Giuliani's generally increasingly
disheveled appearance anyway let's go to
the substance now I think we should let
doctors decide whether we should use
hydrochloric win not the National
bureaucracy you know this this disease
can kill you and if hydrochloric win has
side effects none of which are death by
the way then those side effects I may
want to endure because of the risk of
death and it may be different if I'm 25
or if I'm 75 those choices should be
given to doctors not to the bureaucrats
in Washington who want to go through
three blind tests when we finish the
three blind tests
you know most of America could be gone
and they sit there in an ivory tower
whereas the guys sitting at Mount Sinai
in hospital with the person walking in
who's 65 year old 65 years old 104
temperature and I set one there just the
other day first thing they did before
they even talked to him is give him
hydroxychloroquine and it's banned in
New York by the governor why is the
governor banning it everything shows
that it works everything shows that its
side effects don't bother you until you
take it for a month or two for chronic
illness like rheumatoid arthritis or
lupus
five administration's of it so far no
side effects Rudy says let's let doctors
decide that's who is deciding we don't
need Rudy and Trump saying try it and
this is the new game that they're
playing they're acting like it's
bureaucrats who are making decisions
about medications that's not true the
FDA has approved for emergency use
really quickly emergency use of
chloroquine if determined appropriate by
a doctor the side effects are never
death Rudy says that's wrong and in fact
there's something called chloroquine
poisoning people with heart problems can
end up dying from taking doses of
chloroquine there are peer-reviewed
studies about this Rudy says cleric wins
banned in New York that's not true they
are repeating this but it is not true
New York and some other states have
restricted access to chloroquine to
avoid stockpiling of the drug there are
exemptions for clinical trials there are
exemptions for patients hospitalized
with coronavirus if the doctor
determines it's appropriate these are
all lies and as you all know I've been
talking about chloroquine longer than
Trump I have been telling you this is
one of dozens of possible treatments we
want to test it but Trump now being so
in favor of it
Rudy being so in favor of it we found
out Novartis which manufactures it paid
Michael Cohen a million dollars for
access to Trump when we look at this
from a political perspective it's things
to high heaven from a medical
perspective chloroquine should be try
safely when determined by doctors as one
of many our CTS randomized clinical
trials and we should see what comes of
it and it just doesn't stop on Fox News
with the chloroquine there's a YouTube
channel we're partnering with that I
would love for you to check out it's a
channel called up flip you can get there
by clicking the link below make sure you
subscribe when you're there every week
up flip uploads a new video where you
get an exclusive behind-the-scenes look
at a different small business everything
from real estate firms coffee shops auto
repair shops each business owner shares
a ton of really interesting insight
about how they built their business what
it's like day-to-day how they got to
where they are fascinating to learn
about other people's business strategies
how they found success it's a great
channel for anyone thinking of starting
a business already running one or just
people interested in how different
business work perfect for people who
like TV shows like shark tank and that
type of thing check it out at david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
underneath the video they are friends of
the David Pakman show make sure to
subscribe when you're there click that
Bell icon to be notified when they
upload new videos